our next guest Tony nominated actor and
composer Sara Bareilles has taken her
hit musical waitress to the big screen
waitress the musical live on Broadway
was reimagined and recorded as a feature
film it premiered this week at the New
York's Tribeca Film Festival take a look
[Music]
there is
[Applause]
[Music]
that is varela's singing she used to be
mine from waitress I got a little
distracted listening that's right we got
lost in the sauce there she created the
music and the lyrics and starred as the
lead character Jenna on Broadway I will
say she's a triple threat but that'd be
selling her very very short yeah good
morning how are you doing I'm so good so
waitress received several Standing
Ovation at this week's Tribeca Film
Festival why did you want to share this
Broadway show in this way
so I was one of those people who grew up
in a small community that didn't have
access to you know mainstream theater so
I grew up watching these wonderful PBS
specials things like into the woods
um you know and great performances and
the Rogers and Hammerstein Cinderella
and
um that's how I got my dose of theater
and how I nurtured that love for it and
I feel like we got this opportunity to
capture waitress with this cast in this
moment and we just couldn't pass it up I
want to you know I want this to be
indelible forever I just the show is
you know the love of my life it is the
love of mine so are there plans to bring
this film version of waitress to a
larger audience that is the Hope
of the Tribeca Film Festival right now
which is the first time Tribeca has ever
featured a theater piece in this way so
we did this amazing collaboration we had
this massive screening in Times Square
hundreds of people came out they stayed
in the rain to watch
um the the broadcast on the TSX screen
in Times Square we've sold out every
showing at Tribeca so there's obviously
a huge appetite for this
um look at that they're sitting in the
rain oh Angels what did it feel like for
you Sarah I mean you are obviously a
very successful singer but you were also
a theater kid to see your Creation in
the lights in Times Square I mean how
did that feel it's it's surreal it's um
humbling it's it's so it's such a rich
experience and I will say sitting in
that theater watching this live capture
with all of my castmates my bandmates
our creative team you know our set
designers like watching this thing that
is so handmade get this moment to be
captured forever just feels so precious
so it was it was Unforgettable I'm still
riding the high clearly I'm not even
that caffeinated right now I'm happy
speaking of forever uh you're engaged
your fiancee
and
um you met there right I mean that was
where you first saw each other yes I had
a crush on him since his audition he
walked in what I love is that he plays
your crappy husband I know he's really
good I want to hear more about what
happened when he walked in I did I I did
go to my creative team and I said I will
volunteer to rehearse with Joe today
had a big crush on Joe and um yeah we're
almost eight years in now how has he
encouraged your continued growth
professionally personally oh in every
way I mean Joe is is a really special
partner for me he's he's incredibly
attuned to where I run into my own
vulnerabilities and he's always he's
what a partner should be where there
they see where you need some confidence
boosting and he's always encouraging me
to do the brave thing yeah do you guys
give each other feedback on on stage and
acting relationship not if we want to
stay engaged
with my wife and I have this for sure
and she'll sometimes have like little
people gone this morning and I'll be
like yeah it depends on your state of
mind and there lies the key to a good
relationship know what not to say yeah
um so you recently attended the Tonys as
a nominee for best leading actress and
this was into the woods yeah now you've
been nominated before but that was for
best score so what is it like to have
these nominations for something that's
so passionate to you I mean it this felt
like one of those real pinch me moments
because when I was a little kid this is
the thing I imagined was being on stage
and being one of the storytellers and
singing and so working on waitress
originally as the composer you know I
was more behind the scenes which I
adored but it was it's a very different
thing getting acknowledged for your own
performance and being the one in the
spotlight so I I just I have so much
reverence for the theater community and
the level of craft that that happens
here and so to be acknowledged in this
way was amazing so really quickly your
dream was to be on the Broadway stage
not necessarily be a successful musician
which you also are that's right wow
okay that's what I'm talking about wait
a special this year thank you so much
success waitress the musical live on
Broadway is screening at the Tribeca
Film Festival visit Tribeca film.com for
available tickets